[Music]
so time then for the press preview it's
a first look at what is on the front
pages of sunday's papers and tonight
we'll see what's making the headlines
with katie balls deputy political editor
of the spectator and david clegg editor
of the courier of a good evening to both
of you we'll chat in a second after
we've had a look at some of those front
pages for you beginning with the
observer it goes with senior
conservatives accusing boris johnson of
being delusional after he said he was
already planning for his third term as
prime minister
mr johnson will try to win back support
in red wall seats this week as he tries
to protect the british steel industry
that's according to the sunday telegraph
well after a week of transport
disruption the sunday express says the
prime minister has been urged not to
give an inch to striking rail staff
while the sunday times leads with a
claim prince charles accepted cash
donations from a qatari shake clarence
house has told us tonight charitable
donations received went straight to one
of the prince's charities which says all
the correct processes were followed
meanwhile the sunny mirror claims the
home secretary pretty patel has broken
the law over her treatment of asylum
seekers in barracks in kent
with wimbledon returning on monday the
star leads with a warning to tennis fans
not to sneak off
into the woods
goodness and in the sunday people wayne
rooney reveals that he quit the
manager's job at derby county for his
wife colleen
and don't forget you can scan that qr
code that you will be able to see during
the programme it means that you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
papers while you watch us discussing
them and as i say i'm joined tonight by
katie paul's deputy political editor at
the spectator david clegg is also with
us editor of the courier of course um so
let's get cracking shall we why don't we
start katie with this story on the front
of the
sunday telegraph now the prime
minister's plans uh we steal tariffs
have have been knocking around for a few
days now but obviously uh the uh
by-election results on uh thursday have
perhaps um focused his mind
yes and you can see helen's being
positioned as a policy that will win
borah johnson support in the red hall
which is a particularly contentious
subject at the moment after the tories
lost the wakefield by-election to labour
it's also as you say a policy we have
heard of before and that's not just
rumors of it uh when you had the
resignation of lord gait he was the
prime minister's what was the prime
minister's um ethics advisor his second
uh since he entered 10 downing street
and he said that the reason he had
resigned was he'd been put in an odious
position and i think lots of people
thought oh it could be party gate it
could be wallpaper gate but actually um
what uh pushed lord white over the edge
was uh boris johnson's plan to um
to ultimately come up this policy which
could be in breach of world trade
organization rules and collegiate
retaliation and this is confirmation i
think that the government is going to be
pressing on of it we could get announced
next week and while it's being is
pitched to something that could um
definitely gain support from those who
stand to benefit from these measures
which should help the uk steel industry
there's enough in this story to point to
some of the problems ahead that is
retaliation and some of the nerves in
other parts of government
yeah and also uh david the the telegraph
saying that that there are fears of a
trade war uh if uh if the prime minister
does break the wto rules um in order to
to protect those jobs as katie says
yeah certainly i think the whiskey
industry especially here in scotland
will be concerned about that they had
problems uh with trump in a in america
because of a trade war and uh boris
johnson sending these kind of signals
will be setting off alarm bells there i
think i think what kiri was saying there
is quite interesting about the fact that
the ethics advisor resigned and it
wasn't because of party gate it was
because of this and there was almost
some kind of mockery of that fact i
think when the resignation happened that
after all the party gates it's boring
steel tariffs that that have caused the
fx adviser to resign
but if you i think if you break that
down that is actually legitimate and
correct and it shows the seriousness of
this issue
the the prime minister of the united
kingdom should be acting uh within
international law that is something that
we would normally have just accepted
that would be the case that democratic
norms and international law would be
upheld by the by the prime minister
we're we're not in that situation as
we've seen with some of the rhetoric and
some of the positioning around the
northern ireland protocol and part of
that uh brexit
conundrum but also in this as well which
if if we really get to the bottom of it
what this is is that he thinks this
could be popular in some seats uh in the
north of england uh where there's been
traditional steel industry and that
there's there's concern and frustration
for i think understandable reasons about
cheap import of of steel
that is something that should be worked
on that is something where there should
be support for industry if there is that
problem but to do it by breaking
international law
isn't isn't the actions of a of a
government acting in a responsible way
so i i think it's it's a further uh
trajectory of boris johnson's character
reflecting the approach of his
government which i think is quite
concerning really um let's move on casey
to the front of the observer uh the
prime minister has been speaking today
to our political editor beth rigby um
and there's a lot of fighting talk there
isn't there following on from uh those
two by-election losses also of course
losing uh
um mr dowden as well um but he's being
accused by the observer of being
delusional when he talks about wanting a
third term
yes um and this was an exchange earlier
today where the prime minister's asked
if he thought he would you know go for a
second term if that was really feasible
in the face of these two by-election
defeats on friday all the other problems
that boris johnson is currently having
um internally with his own party if you
think about the recent no-confidence
vote and his reply was actually my
mind's really more on the third term um
which is fighting talk and here you have
some mps and others branding it as
delusional talk um i do think if you
step back for a second though i mean i
don't think it's uncommon for a prime
minister under pressure to dismiss the
idea that they would you know step down
or even go after a second term
i think what the prime minister will be
trying to do is to end the speculation
by coming out very strong but ultimately
we're in a situation where i think boris
johnson is going to find it really
difficult
in the coming months to
to draw a line as much as number 10 say
you know the confidence vote was won we
can move on i think it's proving harder
and harder to do and actually the
by-elections are just a further
weakening of his authority
and it means every time he says things
like this i think fewer people believe
it although david he did um uh admit
stuffing up over certain issues didn't
he today
in his in his characteristic flippant
way he did yes but he quickly pointed
out that he thought the public was over
that now and we need to move on on to
other matters that they were sick of
hearing about him stuffing up i guess
one approach to that would be to stop
still stuffing up so regularly but uh i
think i think one of the interesting
issues here is that he's talking about
you know staying on until the 2030s
which of course would involve a third
term will involve an election victory
and based on the evidence of the two
by-elections this week that that looks
like it's a optimistic proposition at
best and i'm i'm really interested in
what the audience of not not the public
at large but conservative mps and
conservative activists are making of
this because they must be feeling
uh fairly concerned about their position
in the wake of those by-election results
and also on i'm
i'm not blaming the prime minister for
this because he's actually been like
he's been out of the country on
important business and i think he's in
munich tomorrow for the g7 so that that
is continuing but also it is quite
notable that he's been out of the
country throughout this whole period so
he hasn't really been able to
uh get a grip of that situation and do
the kind of talking to the grassroots
that might be required in the wake of an
unsettling uh two by-election defeats
like that so while he is talking tough
here while to listen to his rhetoric you
would feel that he's feeling very
comfortable
i think that those uh tory
voices that are in the observer calling
him delusional uh are
probably have probably have some
legitimacy around that argument because
given the polling given the
the history of the last six months and
given the results that he had during the
week
i think for the prime minister to be
thinking about the 2030s does look very
optimistic okay um i just want to
squeeze in a couple of quick front pages
uh before the break katie tell me about
this story on the front of the mirror
about pretty patel
yeah so this is ultimately pretty breaks
law in another assignment scandals in
mirror's headline and effectively is
saying that um the high court has ruled
that housing refugees um in barracks and
kent until 2026 draws a plan it is not
going to be something that the home
office will be able to do it breaches um
what how you would expect it to treat an
individual and so i think it's just
adding to that sense that when it comes
to the government's immigration policy
government can talk very tough but it
constantly hits issues with it um i
think the government's clear solution to
this of course is try and stop many
people from coming here in the first
place but as we've seen in the sense
that um
you know the flight did not take off to
rwanda um that policy is gonna be some
time in the making to have the desired
effect the government wants it to have
and if it is going to have that at all
so lots of problems in the in the medium
term before you get to that
okay and uh on the front of the sunday
telegraph uh david you mentioned the g7
uh and nato summits
that are coming up soon the foreign
secretary um has been warning uh certain
leaders not to sell out ukraine
yeah this is this is liz trust who's
talking about the uh in fact it's a
joint article for ukrainian counterpart
which i think again shows that uh
closeness that there is between the the
uk administration and the ukraine
government saying you know that they're
and i think they're particularly worried
about macron they're particularly
worried about about france and whether
there's a certain fatigue in countries
in europe about this war about the fact
that there's maybe a sense that the that
some of the governments would like to
get this this situation off their radar
we'd like to move on we'd like to put
that situation in the past and perhaps
would be willing to capitulate and make
compromises with putin that uh certainly
the ukrainians don't want to make and
the uk are coming in behind them very
strongly here in this this joint albeit
with liz trust and saying that that
can't be allowed to happen and i believe
that boris johnson is going to be making
similar remarks in his speech in munich
uh tomorrow so it is this uh
very clear sense now that the uk is one
of the ukrainians strongest allies in in
europe during this conflict
uh yeah i'm just reading now uh those uh
exact words the prime minister is going
to tell leaders that uh zolensky needs
western backing more than ever at that
meeting in germany okay we'll leave it
there for the moment thank you both
coming up we'll continue the press
preview featuring this matte cartoon on
the front page of the sunday telegraph
which takes aim at the rail strikes
telling you about that and more in a
couple of minutes
[Music]
[Music]
part two of the press preview katie and
david still with us let's talk about the
rail strikes shall we another day of uh
strikes today of course uh katie front
of the sunday express crackdown on
militant
unions um still doesn't seem to be
a resolution in sight
yes again we're hearing about the
government's plan to crack down on the
unions but when it comes to how they
plan to do this i think it's fairly
scant on details
and as you say when it comes to the
talks between the various sides it's not
coming too much and therefore i think
everyone is braced for more disruption
more strikes i think what's interesting
in this piece is uh one of the things
that people are saying to the government
and as being said within government
about um the pay demands and how you
respond to them is actually don't give
them much at all because if you do
you'll encourage everyone to then have
more strikes in various different
industries and so i think you always
potentially are toughening up of the
government lying on strikes as this goes
on
and i think if you're thinking about
where the political pain is when it
comes to which party is blamed for
strikes
i think last week was probably the
government's easiest week on strikes
because it was the first week and
therefore actually was kierstarma who
was facing lots of questions about uh
you know was his party united on the
issue i think if we do have a summer of
disruption and chaos um eventually
people will look to the government to
say well are you is this really going to
keep going on is that sustainable um so
for all the fighting talk i mean i think
the government to face down the unions i
think that doesn't happen in you know
even a few weeks or months time it gets
quite uncomfortable for the tory
government too yeah it's interesting
david today getting uh getting the views
of members of the public at the goodwood
festival of speed thousands of people
travel there despite the the rail strike
and the vast majority of them were
actually saying you know what we we
managed to get here uh without too many
problems there wasn't a huge amount of
traffic on the roads um you know
it was okay i mean do you think there is
a sense amongst the public that we're
all so used to home working now that
we're so used to choosing not to commute
into into cities and work from home that
actually um
there isn't going to be that huge
pressure from the public and indeed many
members of the public may may well
support uh the strikers given that their
own finances are under strain
i think certainly there's sympathy for
uh people being offered two to three
percent pay rises when inflation's
running at nine percent and could rise
to eleven percent i think i think that's
certainly the case and also the point
you make on the kind of effect of the
pandemic and
the
working from home that was certainly the
experience uh for me this week uh i'm in
dundee here during the strike there was
new trains to glasgow edinburgh old and
he was effectively cut off from the rest
of scotland in its entirety but i think
because people are so used meetings were
rescheduled to zoom
and all the rest of it so the in some
ways the practicalities of of dealing
with with that uh not being able to
commute in the same way is is easier
annoying but i think that's okay because
it was just one day or or a couple of
days if it gets into a prolonged
situation and also if it begins to
affect holidays because
the rmt have said that more strikes
could be coming down the road and we we
imagine that that will hit key summer
periods we also know that there's talk
about strikes at the airports and there
could there could be a reverberation
into other sectors as well so i think i
think katie is right that if this summer
of discontent starts to bubble over that
it will become another issue for the for
the conservative government labor as
they always do whenever their strikes
will have some internal battles about
that and issues on positioning and how
supportive they are in public or private
uh for the various industrial disputes
but i i i think ultimately the the
public have been fairly patient so far
but that their patience could run out as
well yeah matt has a great cartoon in uh
in the telegraph um he so often hits a
nail on the head doesn't he a picture
here of an estate agent showing a couple
uh around a new house this property is
an absolute bargain says the estate
agent it's close to a train station so
it's cut off from everywhere um i mean
katie one of the issues is that uh the
rmt uh and uh grant shaps as well
they've been using pretty strong
language against each other haven't they
i mean it doesn't sound like they're in
any sort of mood for
sitting around the table and and having
a calm discussion not at the moment
no it really doesn't and i think that's
partly because actually
for at least at this point i think there
are some on the tory side you think that
you can actually get you can win
political capital from the strike row
and
for the reasons we just outlined i don't
think that is uh something that will
continue to be the case if lots of
people cannot go on holiday if people
are having their flights canceled if you
cannot get to where you need to see your
family yeah um
and i think actually eventually some
people do need to potentially go to the
office um
employers will be more relaxed
perhaps about one week so all these
problems will build up a bit um and i
think that therefore the rhetoric on
both sides is hardening and it does mean
that if we get to a point where
everything is you know really building
up to a crescendo um it's hard to see
where the compromise or common ground is
going to be found i don't think
particularly when the government is
hardening its line on pay um and also
that's what across government foreign
also saying there will be pay rises but
they will not be large i think it's a
really tricky line from politicians who
in many cases earn six figure salaries
to say oh
a pay rise of nine percent if you think
of so many salaries you know is is you
know excessive i think that is a tricky
political line depending on what
yourself
all right we must leave you there